Dishonored 2 is finally out and well if
you haven't played the first one it may
seem a little overwhelming the game
isn't designed to hold your hand and if
you don't know what you're doing you may
not get the most out of it
so here's some things to keep in mind
when you begin your journey to take back
the throne first off you can choose from
two characters this time around emily
kaldwin or the now gravelly voiced Corvo
attano don't worry about the rabble
rousers and we'll catch the crown killer
eventually apart from the obvious
differences between the two characters
they each have some unique abilities
these skills called enhancements are the
same between the two the only power that
they both share word-for-word is dark
vision this power allows you to spot
guards through walls and eventually see
guards routes it's definitely worth
investing in another ability that they
both kind of share is blink if you've
played the first one then you know blink
basically allows you to teleport emily
has far reach in stead like blink this
will help you get around the map easier
and get the spots you normally couldn't
reach one thing to keep in mind is that
enemies can see you if you far reach
past them you don't blink in and out of
existence as you would with Corvo
depending on how you play it's important
to research each character's ability for
example if you plan on playing
non-lethal stealth is Corvo then you
might want to invest in possession
and Bend time these skills will help you
slip past unnoticed but say you want to
play stealth as Emily instead well it
might be worth investing in shadow walk
and ability that makes it more difficult
to be spotted bring it on
and mesmerise as you'd expect this
distracts cards
something comforting about this to get
these powers you'll need something
called runes and this brings me to my
next point where your heart on your
sleeve or rather carrion it's worth
assigning the heart to a quick slot so
you can frequently pull it out and see
if there are any runes or bone charms
and you're by now some of these can be
rather difficult to get my
recommendation is to try your hardest to
get all the rooms you can but if you're
having a difficult time with a bone
charm it won't be the end of the world
if you pass it up by those within the
outsiders wicked cabal those carson
figures while you're searching for these
runes you will probably come across a
few black markets unless you're in a
hurry
do not buy the rune or anything apart
from the blueprints for that matter
though the game doesn't explicitly tell
you this you can rob these stores
sometimes they can be a bit of a detour
but it's definitely worth the trouble
just remember that when you rob one of
these stores you can no longer purchase
the blueprints so I'd make sure to pick
those up first
the next question you should ask
yourself is how do I want to play
Dishonored is known for its deep and
complex gameplay choices you can play
lethal non-lethal stealth or assault
obviously the choice is yours but I
would recommend taking the stealthy
approach from there you can either play
lethally or non-lethal aid however if
assault is more your style just keep in
mind that the sword combat is kind of
clunky and the second you get
outnumbered things are going to get real
difficult
if you chose to heed my advice and play
stealth here are some useful strategies
for one use blink and far reach a lot
the higher up you are an environment the
safer you are hide the bodies or better
yet turn them to ash hiding bodies
should be a no-brainer for anyone who's
played a stealth game but if you plan on
taking the lethal route it's definitely
worth investing in shadow kill it
basically saves you the mess finally be
patient and explore your environment
Dishonored two's areas are dense and
layered with tons of quests lore and
secrets if you rush through these
missions you will undoubtedly miss out
on some of the coolest scenarios and you
will probably also make your life much
more difficult if you have any other
hints or tips that I may have missed
leave them in the comments below or you
can let me know on twitter at jacob deck
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and good luck in Karnataka